hey what's wrong man
i was having a nightmare oh
again
but you want to talk about it i miss
mommy
hey i know i know it's hey me too me too
pal
come here man it's
all right hey it's okay it's gonna be
okay
i just don't want anything ever happened
to you happened to me
hey come on man ain't nothing ever gonna
happen to me
really
yeah that's what i said so yes
that i'm nothing never gonna happen to
me you ain't never gonna have to worry
about nothing happen to me
but what if what if you got hit by a car
or something
that's impossible because i will never
die
so i can't die
no matter what you can't die but i
thought
all human beings died
that's true that's true that's science
so that's true but i
am lucky cause i'm i'm not a human
you're not i never told you about this
no you know i'll just let it out i'm
from a planet
called felonious the thing
is it was being destroyed all right
that's what happened my was i was sent
down here
in in a capsule to earth by my parents
oh like superman superman
yep that is what it is exactly like
except oh here's the thing about my
version
only one super power immortality oh
yeah so i'm tired daddy's tired
can you let's go to sleep okay listen
but i'm not gonna live forever
right because because i'm only half
alien
oh no so i'm gonna
die mm-hmm uh-huh mm-hmm
you you you write about yourself
ex but
here it is this one slit my mind
you can build with me
immortality the machine to give you
what i got from the remnants of my
spacecraft
so yeah wow you're gonna be immortal
you're gonna be immortal daddy when are
we gonna get the remnants
tomorrow tomorrow
gonna get them tomorrow darren work
hey you got anything that looks like
parts of a crash spaceship
dead mom mm-hmm right this week